[Musica]
effetto domino nell'economia
cosa vuol dire domino e dominio
ora a tutti noi forse non a tutti però
io sono assolutamente nel gruppo ci
piacerebbe dominare tutti gli eventi
esterni trovare le migliori opportunità
ridurre il rischio o eliminarlo
addirittura ma riusciamo è veramente
possibile fare una cosa del genere è
veramente possibile dominare l'ambiente
in cui ci muoviamo
allora togliamo ogni possibilità di
dubbio ce lo togliamo subito così poi
siamo tranquilli non è possibile non ce
la potremo mai fare
però noi possiamo fare alcune cose
viviamo sentiamo sempre più spesso dire
che viviamo in un mondo globale digitale
velocissimo ma andiamo mai dall'altra
parte del mondo in un nanosecondo quando
serve funzionano e viaggiamo da una
parte all'altra del mondo ma cosa vuol
dire poi vivere quali sono gli effetti
del dell'essere in un mondo globale
allora io vorrei leggere con voi questi
sono degli eventi che hanno provocato
delle crisi a livello mondiale negli
ultimi 100 anni primi del novecento
quindi ci possiamo scorrere velocemente
insieme prima guerra mondiale 15 18 la
grande depressione del 29
la seconda guerra mondiale o software
prolifero il 73 più 70 per cento sul
pezzo il prezzo del petrolio quindi non
c
non ci meravigliamo su quello che sta
succedendo adesso
2001 torri gemelle 2003 l'aviaria lehman
brothers nel 2008 che si è portato
dentro la crisi del debito il 2011 kobe
del 2020 guerra in ucraina fate conto
che
ufficialmente l'era digitale parte nel
2002 quindi tra le torri gemelle
l'aviaria
questo perché il numero dei dati che
sono stati digitalizzati in quel
passaggio estremamente in più importante
degli anni precedenti quindi la
disponibilità per tutti dei dati di
qualsiasi tipologia è stata estremamente
più ampia e quindi si dice che l'era
digitale sia partita da lì poi in realtà
vediamo che gli effetti globali di aveva
molto prima chiaro la digitalizzazione
lia velocizzate
però questi effetti hanno effetti sulle
nostre vite ed effetti soprattutto
sull'economia
vi vorrei però far ragionare su un paio
di altre cose
la prima cosa che
qualsiasi nome diamo ad una crisi che
sia globale
è abbastanza ciclica una volta una
guerra una volta è una pandemia ma è
ciclica
e soprattutto se guardate un po le date
un uomo che ha un'età media di 75 anni
vive almeno quattro crisi nella propria
vita di cui 2 spesso nella proprietà
lavorativa
alla domanda è come mai non siamo mai
pronti perché non siamo pronti sapendo
che qualcosa arriva non ne conosciamo il
nome non ne conosciamo l'entità non
sappiamo da dove parte ma sappiamo che
avrà un effetto perlomeno economico
importante a livello globale
la pandemia del 2020 ha portato
chiaramente una forte pressione sulla
parte sanitaria con tutto quello che
conoscete ma anche portato una forte
pressione a livello economico
molte aziende hanno chiuso persone sono
rimaste senza lavoro e quindi ci ha
schiacciato quello che
normalmente sentiamo dire era
inevitabile come si faceva non fallire
molti imprenditori dicono impossibile
abbiamo chiuso tutto quindi erano non si
poteva uscire da questa situazione
c'è una sola regola certa in tutte
quelle crisi che avete visto che c'è
sempre qualcuno che nelle crisi vince
sempre questa è l'unica regola fissa le
crisi possono cambiare gli impatti
possono essere più o meno notevoli ma
c'è sempre qualcuno che vince durante le
guerre mondiali le aziende che facevano
meccanica sono state riconvertite per
produrre armi durante il copy da alcune
aziende tessili hanno prodotto prodotto
mascherine qualche azienda della
refrigerazione ha prodotto bombole per
l'ossigeno
e ci sono stati alcune aziende che hanno
veramente
incrementato i loro fatturati in maniera
importantissima tutta la grande
distribuzione organizzata ipermercati
supermercati
un paio di giorni fa ho ricevuto una
telefonata da un cellulare a la risposta
è partito un messaggio automatico che mi
diceva le azioni amazon nel periodo del
copy 19 sono incrementate del 150 per
cento ora chiaramente era un invito
all'investimento però proviamo a leggere
il messaggio una delle più grandi
aziende mondiali ha incrementato nella
più grande crisi mondiale del 150 per
cento le proprie azioni
a questo punto mi dire te va bene allora
la grande distribuzione eravamo chiusi
in casa però dovevamo comprare il cibo
amazon spedì spediva i prodotti a casa
quindi in qualche maniera è la crisi che
definisce chi vince chi perde
in parte è vero in parte
ma non totalmente vero
io faccio un esempio che cosa è stato di
tutti i ristoranti che hanno dovuto
chiudere perché non hanno più più
accogliere clienti molti sono falliti
qualcuno ha avuto un incentivo statale
hanno provato a sopravvivere io ho un
amico chef a milano
lui fa alta cucina
che vuol dire non solo preparare un
piatto vuol dire
tutta una un certo atteggiamento verso
il piatto la costruzione del piatto ci
sono delle reazioni chimiche che ske al
palato arrivano in una determinata
maniera all'abbinamento del vino che
storia c'è quale la genesi dietro quel
piatto come viene servito qual è il
locale dove dove ti siedi come te lo
raccontano quindi è tutto un insieme che
con il lock down andava perso lui a un
certo punto chiusi ristorante ha chiuso
il ristorante
e ha cercato di capire come doveva fare
e si è inventato nel periodo da di
spacchettare il proprio prodotto perché
qual era il problema il problema era che
portare il proprio cibo a casa dei
clienti durante la più grande crisi
mondiale sarebbe voluto dire entrare in
un territorio di massa
dove c'è qualsiasi tipo di cibo dove ti
arriva alle pizze fredde a casa e fai
finta di niente io no mia moglie lo sa
mi dà fastidio però in generale la
qualità non ci fai tanto caso secondo
elemento come cercare di far arrivare
l'alta cucina deriverà ndola lui ha
spacchettato il prodotto non ha chiuso
il piatto lo ha venduto tramite il web
insieme a un tutorial in cui raccontava
come finire il piatto a casa
quindi ha mantenuto più o meno il
livello della qualità alta
cioè fatto anche sentire un po chef per
un'oretta grandi chef e in un momento in
cui avevamo assolutamente del tempo da
impiegare
il risultato è stato che la sua brigata
con lui dentro sono hanno lavorato tutti
i giorni durante il lock down hanno
spedito il cibo attraverso un sito web
che era stato costruito precedentemente
chiaramente non per l'occasione e questo
sito nel 2021 è stato premiato come il
migliore sito del food a livello
italiano
allora mi direte una questione di
creatività
e anche qui in parte è vero la
creatività ci vuole però guarda te c'è
molta più programmazione c'è molta più
attenzione all'efficienza
c'è molta più rigorosità nel fare queste
cose di quanto si possa pensare
fino ad adesso fino a questo periodo la
programmazione delle aziende era tra i 3
ei 5 anni si programmava con dei dati
molto attendibili oggi tre anni 5 anni
sappiamo quasi esattamente quello che
andrà a cadere e si programmava con la
testa rivolta verso dietro cioè sapendo
quello che sapevi fare guardavi i dati e
davide gli obiettivi a te stesso
marginali di crescita
però questo non ci evitava di uscire
dalle crisi perché quando arrivava all
evento crisi importante la tua
operatività normale non era più
sufficiente
oggi si è fatto un passaggio molto più
importante oggi le aziende programmano a
10 anni
con dati non attendibili non esiste una
programmazione che possa avere un dato
certo a 10 anni non sai cosa accadrà a
pensate dieci anni fa qual è la
situazione e pensate oggi però questo
forza tutti a dare degli obiettivi su
cosa vogliamo essere tra dieci anni non
su come
marginalmente fare un processo ma cosa
vogliamo essere tra dieci anni
a prescindere da quello che succede poi
si torna indietro anno per anno cercare
cercando di capire qual è il mattone che
serve per arrivare ai po il famoso buon
tubi come lo chiamano gli americani tra
dieci anni
la capacità del manager non è più
modificare il cosa ma stabilire come
operare durante l'anno stabilire come
variare le cose che deve fare in maniera
da non cambiare il risultato
il risultato non è più toccabile il
risultato non si tocca più quello che
deve essere rimane è il come che cambia
e questo va treni zato i nuovi manager
sviluppano cercano di sviluppare questa
attività attraverso la programmazione a
10 anni ma anche attraverso l'ossessione
dell'efficienza in momenti in cui non è
necessario essere proprio così
efficienti perché il mio amico chef se
non avesse creato una reazione virtuale
con i propri clienti molto prima della
pandemia non avrebbe venduto neanche un
piatto perché oggi se vogliamo arrivare
a produrre vetture elettriche per il
2035 perché i legislatori hanno deciso
questa cosa ti devi muovere con dieci
anni di anticipo e devi attaccare un
mercato che quello dell'elettrico molto
prima che sia assolutamente necessario
perché si arrivi tardi sei fuori dal
mercato
e questo è il nuovo atteggiamento cioè
anticipare qualcosa che abbiamo visto
prima statisticamente accade non
sappiamo quando non sappiamo come ma
sappiamo che i risultati che portano
sono assolutamente sempre gli stessi non
cambia nulla può essere una crisi può
essere una variazione legislative
guardate questo vi ho portato l'esempio
del ristorante perché non pensiate che
era appannaggio solamente delle grandi
strutture internazionali mondiali
assolutamente no
il problema è passare attraverso uno
spazio piccolo e passarci meglio degli
altri e prima degli altri ma non
possiamo avviarlo non possiamo avviare
la crisi non possiamo avviare che accada
perché viviamo in un mondo globale e
perché quello che accade dall'altra
parte del mondo ci arriva arriva qua
fino a basso allora
quello che verrà le tre cose che mi
preme dirvi sono fondamentalmente
lavorare sul come lavorare con molto
anticipo e l'ossessione per l'efficienza
questo ripeto vale per le grandi aziende
multinazionali varie per e piccole e
medie imprese italiane che sono ancora
la spina dorsale del nostro paese ma che
sono molto più internazionalizzate di
quanto si possa pensare
vale per il ristorante del mio amico
chef vale per le nostre vite perché che
noi vogliamo o ci piaccia o non ci piace
siamo e non possiamo evitare di essere
cittadini globali grazie per
l'attenzione
[Applauso]